Now comes the cool thing and
it's so cool we call it a trick.
I mean, not too many things in
science are called a trick, and
this is called the kernel trick,
all right?
We saw that a,
the linear classifier only depends
on dot products, remember that?
I circled it.
I jumped up and down about it.
So let's define some function K.
Of two points xi and
xj as just being the dot product,
okay, between them, all right.
If I map a data point to some
high dimensional space, so
my function phi here maps x to phi of x,
all right?
Then the dot product.
Whoops, I actually should
write it this way, right?
The dot product k of xi, xj would become
phi of x, transpose phi of xj.
That's what's written right there.
Okay?
And in fact, what I'm actually going to
do is, I'm just going to redefine k,
instead of just being the dot product of
xi and xj, I'm going to have a new k,
right, which is just this dot product
of the, the higher dimensional space.
K stands for kernel, okay, and it's a,
it's, it's a kernel function and it can
be thought of as a similarity function.
Similarity functions the idea
is that they get bigger,
the more similar things are and
you know,
dot products can go from, you can even
think of it as minus 1 to 1, it's true.
So the idea being the most similar is 1,
the least similar is minus 1, okay?
And a kernel function is a similarity
function that is the dot product,
sometimes called the inner product,
of the higher dimensional space.
Okay.
So, I'm going to show you an example in
a minute, but basically the idea is, if
I give you a function of x1, of xi and
xj, some function K, as long as there's
some higher dimensional space in which
that function is just the dot product
of that higher dimensional space.
That kernel is a dot product,
and therefore,
it can be used in our linear classifier.
There's a whole bunch of theory there
about what are called Mercer kernels,
which have to do with what are,
what types of kernels are acceptable.
You basically have to end up with these
positive definite matrices between
your points a couple
of other constraints.
What, most of that doesn't matter.
What matters is that you have to is,
is you, is that you can show that
essentially it's a dot product and
it turns out a lot of functions are.